Keltie night has a big Britney exclusive
hey Kelty Nichelle Gloria I know you
were very jealous because right now I'm
inside Britney Spears this zone this is
an immersive fan experience here in Los
Angeles that is going to blow your mind
we wanted fans to be able to walk
through her world and just step into all
four music videos
[Applause]
for 60 bucks fans can channel their
inner brett dancing and snapping pics
from the nine interactive rooms it took
three months to transform this 30,000
square foot former Kmart into a Britney
shrine how involved was Britney in this
whole thing
what's fans generated but we had
Britney's blessing she was so excited
about the experience that she actually
donated some of her costumes to put on
display which we think is really really
cool that's the dress Britney wore on
Star Search in 1992 her orange body suit
from til the world ends
[Music]
and the iconic toxic flight attendant
dress but can't you see is Britney
planning on coming she is she's really
excited about it and we know that she's
gonna come by
[Music]